in unserem tagesgespräch begrüße ich
jetzt klaus reinhardt in bielefeld der
ist präsident der deutschen ärztekammer
herr reinhardt es gibt ja viele themen
heute zu besprechen da in berlin und
ihre meinung interessiert uns fangen wir
mal mit der priorisierung an da wird ja
immer mehr gefordert von dieser
festgelegten reihenfolge abzuweichen was
sagen sie dazu
ja wir finden das richtig und vernünftig
weil wir ja relativ viel zeit aufwenden
die priorisierung tatsächlich umzusetzen
zu überlegen wer gehört hinein und er
gehört nicht hinein führt auch immer
wieder zu fragestellungen manchmal sogar
auch zu auseinandersetzungen weil
patienten patienten meinen sie gehörten
und jetzt schon dazu dass es selten der
fall ist kommt auch schon mal vor und in
der summe glaube ich geht schneller wenn
wir diese zeit die wir dafür aufwenden
dafür finden könnten um möglichst hilft
zeit zu gewinnen um wirklich schnell
möglichst viele menschen mit einer erste
infos zu versorgen
jetzt stelle ich mir das aber ein
bisschen wie hauen und stechen vorn aber
ich denke es werden viele leute geimpft
werden wie soll das denn gehen
nein das tun wir jetzt ja auch schon
also ich bin heute morgen in meiner
praxis und wir kriegen jetzt für diese
woche 120 im stoßen habe ich gerade eben
erfahren wir haben uns große listen
angelegt wo wir aufgeschrieben haben wer
für die patienten in frage kommen wer
hat vor erkrankungen welche
vorerkrankungen wie schwer ist er
erkrankt an der einzelnen erkrankung das
wissen wir ja als behandelnde ärzte
deutlich besser
diabetiker ist nicht gleich diabetiker
der eine hat schon sekundär schäden
durch den diabetes davongetragen muss
dann früher geben werden als jemand den
gut eingestellten dem wir das hat ohne
weitere folge erkrankungen als solche
dinge werden berücksichtigt und insofern
machen wir jetzt natürlich eine
vernünftige ärztliche priorisierung auch
nach dem priorisierung schema was info
vorgegeben ist aber das ist aufwendig
und in dem moment wo wir ausreichend
impfdosen in den praxen haben um zu
sagen wir ihm
jeden der ihm willig ist ging ist
natürlich schneller wir diesen aufwand
betreiben müssten
es wird auch über rechte der geimpften
gesprochen
das ist wohl so dass man denen natürlich
dann am ende nicht mehr so weitreichende
grundrechts einschränkungen zumuten kann
ist das auch in ihrem medizinischen
sinne dass menschen die geimpft sind
mehr freiheiten haben
ja absolut ich finde wir müssen ja einen
weg aus der pandemie aufzeigen und er
kann nur sein dass dann werden
ausreichend menschen in unserer
gesellschaft geben wird jetzt sind wir
feststellen dass die institute zahlen
dadurch rückläufig sind das kann man ja
erwarten denn wenn man sich anguckt was
in israel passiert ist oder auch in
großbritannien also in den beiden
ländern die höchste ist es durch hilft
und großbritannien sind fast die hälfte
der bevölkerung inzwischen geimpft dann
sehen wir dass dort die inzidenz zahlen
erheblich zurückgehen in israel fast
null sind und das ist natürlich resultat
des impfens und man kann auch beobachten
konnte beobachten dass in israel das
eingesetzt hat der rückgang der uns in
den zahlen als etwa ein fünftel der
bevölkerung geimpft war unter sukzessive
stück für stück hat das zugenommen und
das denke ich werde bei uns dann sollten
wir uns auch eintreten und von dem
moment an glaube ich kann man rechtlich
und auch menschlich den menschen die
brücke währung ihrer grundrechte nicht
mehr vorenthalten
das sieht der deutsche ethikrat so
gesehen auch namhafte stars rechnet also
also aus diesem grunde glaube ich gibt
es sehr viele gründe so zu verfahren ist
er jetzt einmal mehr so diese idee in
den blickpunkt jüngere auch zu impfen
weil die inzidenz 'nen in den kitas in
den schulen so hoch sind was sagen sie
dazu dass es ja eine abkehr von der
bisherigen idee die alpen zu schützen
ja wir haben jetzt ja die bevölkerung
bis zum sechzigsten lebensjahr von 80
runter sozusagen schon zu einem großen
teil geimpft und das ist auch
beobachtbare weil diese
altersgruppe in den krankenhäusern kaum
noch auftaucht und glücklicherweise das
waren ja diejenigen die auch die
schwersten und dramatischen verläufe
hatten und anhäuft und häufigste
tödliche verläufe auch zu beobachten
waren es über ein großes stück
vorangekommen
und wir sind jetzt also ein punkt wo wir
uns überlegen müssen gehen wir weiter
sozusagen rückwärts von oben kommend
oder aber könnte man die strategie
fahrer zu sagen wem sind jetzt die
jungen menschen die zwar nicht schwer
erkranken in der regel aber die
natürlich viel unterwegs sind die
schulen sollen in die in die kitas gehen
sollen und soll war die jetzt unter
umständen impfen beziehungsweise mal
alle die im film ideen zu tun haben
familien und eltern und erzieher und
lehrer dass man die durchimpfung man in
dieser population eben doch ein großes
bretting ein großes großes raten
feststellen kann und das ist unter
umständen oder ideologischen
gesichtspunkten eine vernünftige
überlegungen dazu kommt ja auch dieser
freigabe von astrazeneca in einigen
bundesländern freigabe für alle von der
priorisierung und eben auch für enten
unter der unter 60 gegen das
widerspricht ja den stiko empfehlungen
den empfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission was sagen sie dazu
astrazeneca für menschen unter 60
das ist ja eine freiwillige entscheidung
des jenigen die den impfstoff nehmen
möchte und ich glaube dass man das
durchaus verantworten kann denn die
zahlen die beobachter waren
und da ist das weniger sind ja zwar
höher als sie spontan das spontane
auftreten von prognosen aber immer noch
sehr gering vor allen dingen wenn man es
ins verhältnis setzt was man gutes damit
erzielt indem man gewohnt verläufe
verhindert also schwere brunner
verhindert und auch grundfunktionen
verhindert und vor dem hintergrund finde
ich es angemessen und vertretbar dass
man diesen impfstoff der von manchen
menschen abgelehnt wird weil es
natürlich in seiner berichterstattung
und in dem hin und
ein wenig an der renomee in
anführungszeichen eingebüßten verloren
hat aber so unrecht denn wir haben viele
namenhafte menschen ich nehme jetzt mal
ein lauter macht er sie öffentlich hat
ihn verlassen mit astrazeneca also ich
glaube man kann das gut vertreten und
wird dann das das freiwillig annehmen
möchte weil der impfstoff aktuell nicht
verfügbar ist dann finde ich das eine
gute maßnahme und wir sehen das ja auch
dass das angenommen wird und können
seitdem nicht feststellen dass die zahl
der hirnwellen thrombosen nun noch mal
erheblich zu noch mit über 1 lauterbach
stehen noch die kanzlerin und der
bundespräsident die sich mit als
basilika auch haben impfen lassen und
auch keinerlei genau auch keinerlei
nebenwirkungen vermeldet haben
eine frage noch würde uns diese notfalls
zulassung dieses kurek impfstoffs helfen
das ist ja auch immer wieder in der
diskussion manche fordern dann im
notfall zulassung würde uns das nach
vorne bringen in der ems tempo also ich
bin nicht ein ganz großer fan von
notfall zulassungen wobei man sagen muss
das war vielleicht ein bisschen anders
vor dem jahreswechsel da war er an einem
punkt wo wir wirklich im stoff not
hatten jetzt sehen wir ja doch und
können beobachten dass wir in den
nächsten drei vier wochen erhebliche
zusätzliche mengen impfstoff bekommen
ich glaube alleine 50 millionen
impfdosen bis ende des zweiten quartals
das ist eine menge die wir dann kämpfen
können und vor dem hintergrund glaube
ich muss man nicht unbedingt einen
notfall zulassung betreiben vielleicht
kann man noch mal schauen wenn man sich
jetzt an cook was haben wir an zusagen
von impfstoffen um eine kalkulation
anstellen ob wir durch die notfall
zulassung und das was dann auch
geliefert werden können dafür denkt sich
dann auch noch ab oder besteht noch mal
ein bisschen mehr geschwindigkeit in den
körpern hier bringen könnten wenn das
der fall ist glaube ich kann man darüber
nachdenken
jedoch sind wir jetzt an einem dortigen
punkt also das waren vor
im mittel ist das macht uns hoffnung
klaus reinhardt war dass der präsident
der ärztekammer ganz herzlichen dank
ich danke ihnen